es ist wirklich mancher verrückter ist
etwa direkt vor unserer nahen warum wir
sehen uns einfach nicht genau so ist es
jetzt mit diesem lichtband das von hobby
beobachtern entdeckt ohrdruf und 25
kilometer lang extrem heiß und die
teilchen jugendphänomen bewegen sich
extrem schnell es ist hier bei uns auf
der erde und wir wissen gar nichts über
das phänomen nur einen namen hat es
sonst lief was es damit auf sich hat und
was man schon darüber herausgefunden hat
dass jetzt in science fiction und tour
aus paris herzlich willkommen
polarlichter kennen wir alle werden
durch sonnenstürme an den polen unserer
erde verursacht weil das plasma
ausparken eruptionen auf der sonne dort
viel tiefer in die atmosphäre bei uns
einen drink an das magnetfeld der erde
schirmt die erde baut weniger ab weil
die feldlinien an den magnetischen polen
senkrecht auf die erde zu laufen aber
das jetzt entdeckte lichtband scheint
etwas ganz anderes zu sein war erscheint
lief auch am polar himmel aber es ist
wohl kein polarlicht titel sie nicht
ganz anders wären beim polarlicht
elektrisch geladene teilchen das
leuchten verursachen gibt es im steve
gar keine elektrisch geladenen teilchen
es ist ein absolutes rätsel was da
leuchtet und es gibt noch mehr retten
entdeckt wurde es vom hobby beobachtern
die fotografien von polarlichtern in
einer facebook-gruppe austauschen
sie hatten festgestellt dass dieses
lichtband immer wieder auftaucht und
auch nicht genauso wie polarlichter
aussieht an der university of calgary
zeigten wie es dem physiker und
astronomen bonnerin
er war allerdings keine große hilfe
zitat ich habe keine ahnung was das ist
bevor man allerdings an die erforschung
wien gab es wichtigeres zu tun das ding
brauchte einen namen und so entschieden
sich donovan und die hobby beobachter
ist rief zu nennen in anlehnung an den
film ab durch die hecke in dem tiere zum
ersten mal einen menschen sehen und das
phänomen nennt aber was hat es mit dem
leuchtenden steve aufsicht sondern
betreut auch das satellitenprojekt form
der europäischen weltraumagentur esa e
bike hat ihren drei satelliten das
erdmagnetfeld und donovan konnte den
überflug eines satelliten mit dem
erscheinen von fünf menschen
der satellit war genau durchs geflogen
und die ergebnisse sind der absolute
wahnsinn
das band auf gas bewegt sich mit einer
geschwindigkeit von rund 20.000
kilometern busse nach westen und es ist
jetzt kommt 3000 grad heiß das ist der
absolute wahnsinn das kann sein eine
vermutung war dass es statt elektronen
wie bei polarlichtern protonen sein
könnten
die das leuchten verursachten aber
protonen können keinen leuchten
verursachen
es bleibt also weiter ein geheimnis und
niemand hat auch nur den blassesten
schimmer
worum es sich handeln könnte wenn es
etwas neues gibt dann erfahrt ihr es
natürlich auch hier durch mehr dafür
hier ein abo aufsaugen und vergesst
nicht mehr einen
auf die glocke zu geben hier die videos
die ihr verpasst wenn er klicks um noch
nicht abonniert hat und ansonsten sage
ich hier immer bis dann flattern